[Music]
did you all know
that when a woman conceived or while
when
two partners conceive that the egg
actually chooses
the sperm we are powerful wait no i
thought the sperm
makes its way in the sperm does make its
way in but the
egg ultimately goes up oh
i know we have an article that we talked
about how the
those two people that went into a lady
and then two people that went into it so
she looked at the same time
so she she had twins right uh but the
the twins came out from
uh different dads different dads isn't
that crazy yeah
so they they they said that the sperm
fight each other there had to be two
eggs then
yeah so that's how the twin happens like
two eggs get stuck together and come
down
they came in here at the same time well
maybe like within within like within the
same day i think she's
like a week because sperm lives up to
like five days in there so she was just
freaky
yeah so human eggs release chemicals
called chemoattractants
very scientific which leave a sort of
chemical breadcrumb crumb trail
breadcrumb sounds disgusting to find the
unfertilized eggs throw it on the salad
i love breadcrumbs
so good delicious crunchy too yeah so
they're saying
in this study that um it depending on
the sperm
certain eggs might have a preference so
they might
not even like the sperm being deposited
in them
wow and then they don't really care who
your partner is either so in this study
that like they just sound like girls i
was choosing
sperms that came from different people
like random strangers it preferred
over its partner
because the egg is just trying to choose
the proper genetics like the
genetically the best fit for oh so it's
like
production when you're at the club and
then you do the i'm gonna go dance on
this girl from behind and then she turns
around to check if you're cute or not
yeah and then she either goes okay yeah
she goes
that yeah um exactly yeah it's like how
some girls it's like
well why do some girls have a preference
for like tall guys and it's like oh
maybe like they are very short or they
wanted to up their genetic
they were off they wanted their
offspring to be taller subconsciously
but they didn't even know that i mean
that's what the egg is doing
yeah the egg is doing that all right i
think i got started on twitter and now
girls they they have to date
tall guys what that's what it is that's
the only thing it's not genetic
it's yeah it's social it's like the
steve's like the
tallest person i've ever dated my ex
before him was five
six bart's the tallest person i ever
dated
wait i was like
yeah make me feel good for a second you
didn't care
no all of my boyfriends have been pretty
short except for i had one boyfriend
that was
six foot his name was also steve and
uh yeah and we only did it for five
months and i didn't really like them
that much um
but then all my other ones were five
eight
and five six like they were they're
pretty short i don't even know how tall
my ex-girlfriends were because like
everyone's just short to me
yeah you were stephen is actually so
tall that it hurt my head to kiss him at
first i was like i saw it as a negative
i was like this is too tall
damn five four and a half
five four and a half right here that's
you that's me oh [ __ ] you're a half an
inch taller and the half is real we
tested it yeah that's really there
he has a half an inch too he's always
half
no it's not the hair oh oh but the
tallest girl i ever
like uh uh canoodled was 511.
oh yeah pretty much you're 511. are you
revealing some secrets
um
you were tim let him decide yeah
we'll see who he runs to one day well
it's pretty
dumb so what i'm sorry
are you calling tim dumb eggs are kind
of mean
uh there's a there's a war against sperm
okay in the body like
first of all they got a long way to go
they gotta travel
upstream all of the woman's fluids are
going this way
and the sperm somehow have to swim
then they get to a fork in the road the
egg is only
up one fallopian tube and they gotta be
smart they gotta be smart they gotta be
smart
what fallopian tube do i [ __ ] go to
most of them will get wiped out
this is the only time i was good at
directions see
we're all here and then they it's an
estimated that only 250 total sperm get
to the side of that that's a lot of
fertilization
a lot of the thousands oh thousands yeah
or however however
you're in your load it's millions per
load dude millions go on that chick's
face
yeah did it go through the nasal cavity
to get things oh god
sometimes back then was like you could
swallow it people are dumb dude
people like when you're a kid you
believe so much [ __ ] i know like the
watermelon seeds
don't eat those it'll grow inside of you
yeah i never ate those
mine they say only about 10
of the 250 sperm are able to fertilize
at any given time
so they kind of blink on and off when
they're able to fertilize
so they have to like get in there right
at the second that they're able to first
of all like double dutch
oh yeah only that's like one in
right and then it shuts off or yeah it
flex one
and it literally does that yeah like it
goes like when um they hit the button
and the [ __ ] middle walls come down
[Music]
and this first trying to run out it's
like nope [ __ ]
yeah but you know the the rest get peed
out because that's nice
yuck yeah or these or they come out when
you guys laugh or sneak they ooze out
it's
[ __ ] disgusting you know what's crazy
about the the journey to the eggs
it's a dangerous one it could be over
easy
oh man you know you ever hear something
i want to go protest that joke
god damn damn dude i'm walking on
eggshells now
this is worse wow is this why the wild
enough isn't getting renewed for more
seasons
no it is i just saw you post it it is
many seasons look i'm i'mma let
i'm gonna let you i'mma let you
but oh my gosh are you coming back to
wild now
um i did a couple of episodes because
they're doing a whole old school versus
new school
i saw you bring the tequila on i did i
brought the classic azul this time
you're really trying to get that because
you're thinking it is your theory it is
bruh well now it kind of that it went
viral on twitter like a couple weeks ago
and everyone was tagging me like i
didn't know about this so i saw tim
drinking it
but they still don't want him what the
[ __ ] how are they way before tim how are
they not
this cool or are they or are they just
nagging you frankly maybe
are they they want me to keep being like
guys i [ __ ] love you please and
they're like how do we own him
you're already doing the promo for them
i know pretty much
but whatever i mean try switching brands
for a little bit and see if they start
flirting with you it's funny because
when i posted the picture with all the
jk people with the synchro
people were asking me so much what that
was really yeah i know people in my
comments like damn tim got sick of
classy as well not paying attention to
them switched it up
you guys see if like their stock goes
down like nobody starts posting them
anymore yeah well
do it for a couple weeks dude let's see
if class will reach his own okay
okay do they have instagram yeah i dm
them too
for you do you lie i swear to god i'll
show you after for real
the theme's a down-ass [ __ ] he looks
kind of dumb but he's really down
oh wow because he made fun of tyco
thank you no he was trying to call me
dumb with the tiger joke
that's what it was is that crazy that he
still used taika
taika was just a little sperm like two
years ago
that is crazy wow he actually wasn't
even a spermia he was like being
concocted in bart's balls yeah he was in
bar's balls what do you mean
yeah i just that's math doesn't add up
he's like two to two and a half years so
like three years ago
almost three years okay great nerd
stop being so much fun you're gonna talk
about science around me
i got what nelson's like oh you're that
guy yeah i gotta bring
nelson's presents so fun so the way the
egg picks their favorites is at the last
minute when like there's a couple sperm
that like
are there it like gives the bread crumbs
to once was like hey
it's like a dating show yeah really here
here you you take the breadcrumbs
that's cool goes and it's like that
means the type of sperm was when i got
chosen
yeah that means we all got chosen yeah i
could have heard
crystal dolphin as you were swearing
maybe
is that the new baby shark for tycoon
it's his own song
like i i forgot how we heard this song
but then it's on everyone's vlogs it's
on everyone
the dolphins were getting all jealous of
those baby sharks yeah i guess so but
all right but just the way he acts it
just such changes as soon as the song
comes on
no it's just it just it like if taika
had his own theme song
that would be like if you heard the song
you're like okay that's tight it's like
if you play mac dre in the bay and
everyone starts going everyone goes
crazy that's his backstory dude
baby [ __ ] goes [ __ ] viral too because
because
babies watch it over and over and over
and over again so like this [ __ ] has two
billion views sometimes
whoa it's crazy my parents don't want to
take care of the kids so just give them
youtube exactly you get my ipad in the
crate i've seen crib ipads
oh they put it slightly so like the
babies laying there and then they slide
them into like a little
i've always wanted to get one of those
things because i i get my arms hurt
when i'm watching stuff in bed but like
have you seen the ones just you just
laid down and just like that you just
put your phone
i saw people do that with nintendo
switch dude yeah i saw them making their
own contraptions to do that
catch us down with the tv just put
whatever you're watching on you got to
turn your head like
yeah if you're laying in bed you they're
saying like you put it right here oh
uh i put a tv on the ceiling yeah i saw
a guy just would like he was laying
under his glass table and just put the
ipad on the glasses
that's pretty good yeah that's smart
it's so funny and weird
but it makes sense but if you walked in
on that it looks so [ __ ] odd yeah
i'd rather walk in on somebody like
beating off you would rather walk it on
someone beating
you didn't see that you put a little
david under his table oh
david nadine yeah beating off beating it
hard
then a guy laying under a glass table
with his legs if i do that to beat off
without the bullet
i don't need both that's double weird
like he's watching the porn under yeah
pretty clever well that would be what
you do because you use both hands you
said i do
what do you do like this no no no no i
i use i use one hand to stroke and the
other ones i caress the balls sometimes
can you show me and i want to see if it
feels good
sure it's like a bong now yeah yeah
pretty much i refuse to caress my own
balls because i feel like
it shouldn't be that good does that make
sense do you feel like drinking i
shouldn't feel that good yeah yeah yeah
because you just need to
yeah i always get i'll be overstimulated
or something
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no i take my time good
to my body let's talk about vibrations
fall in love with yourself
yeah kinda yeah like oh what if i don't
need her anymore yeah
impossible impossible you think so [ __ ]
yeah
the same way we need guys still like the
you can't replicate the
the dick well i suck my own dick one
time and it's comparable to yours
you're on my dick to
are you even like jacking off i don't
like dragon yeah
he did it recently he did one he did
once like i had to
yeah well because she she was not in the
mood why did you have to there was she
was not on the
there's only been like twice in our
whole relationship that he's told me
that he jacked off because
mostly he just doesn't do it well i do i
don't know he just comes out just like
do you come in the room like you did a
good thing like
i did it no i did this for you
it was more than you made me do this it
was in the context because everything
there's like a bunch of heavy [ __ ] going
on i think he wasn't in the mood for
nothing and i was like i got a jerk off
[ __ ] this [ __ ] but then you tell her
but i told her afterwards like i could
jerk off through the heavy [ __ ]
i had to just to [ __ ] you know so
many people jack off their heavy [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i mean like grieving kind of makes
you horny yeah like
if something sad happens like i won't
eat i'll still jack off
yeah same or if i'm not feeling good
sometimes i feel like oh let me just
jack off maybe clear my mind
and just get a little quick little like
endorphin rush you know when i'm
stressed
if i can't sleep i'm like let me waste
energy and
to check off some more yeah dragon off
always helps me sleep well it helps for
sure
yeah oh it doesn't help you sleep why
you get too excited
you get you get energized from it i
guess i just i just think i have a
problem sleeping at night i'm up all day
or like wake up late or whatever but
dragon after them i've fallen asleep so
fast after jacking off like i'll wake up
to like an open laptop yeah
try jacking off slow you know take your
time i do sometimes it'll lull you to
sleep maybe
yeah maybe yeah you're drinking off too
furiously i think yeah i think you're
going to sweat
no i think you i'm sweating next time
you're going to jack off just facetime
us we'll guide you through it yeah
i just think you're really beating it
man you know i think you're really
really beating it well that's what they
call it being off no i know but if
you're crossing off you want me to do
that
yeah just jerk off
maybe it's just or just like a good guy
uh off
good guy off the ball yeah swell guy
good boy
simple off you ain't got the simple whoa
cause you can't zip off your voice
i want to slip off leave us a comment
help nadim jack off better
[Music]
[Music]
foreign